you're sitting at home you know the boys
are running wild and do you ever look at
them and stop and say you know i've been
in the two highest grossing movies of
all time stop it
but it is an amazing achievement i think
it's usually my husband who basically
says you know she's been in the two
highest grossing movies of the world
stop it i never
i need to be reminded that i was i've
been a part of really special projects
and
um cause i'm a workhorse i literally
just i work and then i come home and i'm
working at home and and then i go to
sleep when i wake up and i do it all
over again but then years you know years
pass and moments like this events like
this awards like this compel you to kind
of stop
and look behind you and and
realize that your work has delivered
great results that you have impacted
people in a very special way and that
it's okay to take a moment and breathe
it all in and so it feels it feels quite
special okay here let me give this to
you right now there you go that thing's
heavy yeah
what does that mean to be the star of
the year
i really don't know these
like i think awards are not something
that i've um
i've experienced myself in my personal
career
i've always been happy for others when
they get that recognition i'm rooting
for others
to be in this place feels more like an
out of body experience but it is
compelling me to
to force myself to stand in my own skin
and and be proud and be proud of what
i've done because i've always
been a quiet warrior
it's not about what you say
it's about what you do and i've been
doing a lot for many many years
so
it's good it's good to be recognized you
know you talk about standing in your own
skin you do a lot of social in your
green skin yeah as we get ready for
guardians of the galaxy
[Music]
how much of a kick do you get out of it
and do you ever facetime the boys all
the time you do all the time
and they
you can tell they're always taken aback
by it um i think that secretly they love
it
but deep deep down like i'm always their
mom so i'm definitely not the coolest
person in the room anymore
and that um that's quite humbling
so uh when i am gamora i think i think i
think it's also those 3 30 a.m calls
you know to start your hair and makeup
that that delirium kicks in and you
might as well make something out of it
so my team and i very well peter and i
who are usually up at 3 45 like up and
at it with all those chemicals and all
those fumes yeah we're doing those crazy
videos and they make us really happy
it's also because it's the last
installment this can very well be the
last time they get to do this makeup on
me that they turn me into gamora so
we've been savoring every moment that's
we heard that this is the end and what
will it be like to
i mean you bonded with that crew those
folks the makeup and hair people but
also the stars is that going to be hard
to say goodbye to that group allegedly
of course it will always be bittersweet
but the one thing i'm learning now that
i'm in my 40s and i've been doing this
for 20 years is that
it doesn't have to be the end you know
you can always take it upon yourself to
check in
to get everybody together to have those
dinners to witness everybody in their
great moments and in their not so great
moments and i feel like what made us a
family is that we've been through so
much as the guardians of the galaxy we
all know what happened to james gunn
years ago and that was a test for all of
us and we were the guardians of the
galaxy we had his back and
and we stood strong and we are we feel
tighter than ever it's a really special
group and everybody makes an effort
to love
each other you know to love the other
and that's beautiful um you're also part
of amsterdam yeah
what can you tell us because the cast is
it's crazy it's like every star in the
universe unites i can say that i had a
wonderful experience working with david
o is unique all on its own because of
his personality because of the way that
he works his approach to storytelling is
quite unique to him to who he is i
remember calling jen lawrence and asking
her like hey can you give me some tips
because
i don't know what to expect and she's
like just don't expect anything just
literally don't come with anything
prepared
just be clay because he's definitely a
sculptor and he's going to mold you into
whatever it is that he's looking for and
he's always looking for something it may
seem like he's not right so jen was like
my little lucky charm and i'm so happy i
called her the night before my first day
but i really had a wonderful experience
i was clay and he did mold me like in so
many ways and i'm always like what just
happened is it's gonna be okay i and so
i hope i haven't seen anything but i
hope it's gonna be good you are one of
the most beautiful actresses and a huge
star but you live in a world in your
house of severe male energy twin
seven-year-old twins and a five-year-old
what is that like what is the balance of
those two things because i have all boys
and i know i'm like oh my god the male
energy is real it's really my my dad who
tends to be pretty like good with
zingers and really good you know he's
very witty
he was like be careful because once
again you're the minority here yeah in
every way like the only girl the only
sometimes like the only american
speaking english in the house
um
it's just it's a lot of male energy
i think it's really beautiful it's it's
compelled me to understand
the male species from inception
and i have to say that i'm quite
enamored
with just you males i can find
so many things that you guys could be
doing better
but raising three future men
i can tell you a million things that you
guys were already born with that's
already great you know
and and it's quite special
but it's not for the faint of heart no
it's not is it
[Music]
you